für aufsehen weltweit sorgte die
psychologin susan pinker schon 2008 mit
ihrem bestseller das geschlechter
paradox in dem steht nicht männer sind
schuld an der schlechteren stellung der
frauen in der berufswelt frauen wollen
in der männerwelt oft gar nicht auf die
obersten chefs essen ihr neues buch the
village effekt während vielen internet
begeisterten in die nase stechen
denn jetzt behauptet sie wer zu sehr
online lebt lebt weniger glücklich und
es wäre es noch schneller tod über ihren
400 seitigen beipackzettel zum internet
der auf überraschende weise auch vor
dessen risiken trat wenig mit frau pink
reden aber sie werden sehen es geht auch
im village effekt wieder um interessante
unterschiede wie frauen und männer mit
dem leben umgehen
susan pinker herzlich willkommen sie
schreiten physische begegnungen wie wir
hier von mensch zu mensch hätten eine
ganz andere wirkung als begegnungen die
durch hecken einen elektronischen kanal
vermittelt sind was habe ich mehr jetzt
von unserer begegnung als die
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer zu hause
die durch nahaufnahmen sie vielleicht
noch viel besser und genauer beobachten
können es gibt einen unterschied
zwischen der direkten persönlichen
kommunikation wie wir sie jetzt führen
und digitaler kommunikation
kommunikation über größere distanz
nicht alle formen von sozialen kontakten
entstehen auf gleichheit
so wird wenn sie mit jemandem zusammen
kommen eine ganze kaskade von hormonen
und neurotransmittern freigesetzt die
wirken in dieser chemischen stoffe
besteht darin dass sie schmerz kehlen
sie reduzieren stress sie stärken ihr
immunsystem und erhöhen die lust an der
interaktion nicht nur hier und jetzt sie
tun es auch längerfristig wir wissen
dass menschen die viele persönliche
kontakte pflegen eine um zwei bis 15
jahre längere lebenserwartung haben
ich finde das ist unglaublich und das
war neu für mich als ich mit der
recherche für dieses buch an
also ein richtiger face to face kontakt
macht dass ich dann länger lebe wenn ich
jetzt im sky-interview würde bekommt
auch ein bisschen was von den hormonen
oder dank spritzt gar nichts wir haben
noch keine forschungsresultate die sagen
das ist keine wirkung
aber die meisten leute die skype nutzen
wissen dass man keinen wirklichen
augenkontakt hat wegen der position der
kamera
meist ist die kamera auf ihre stirn
fokussiert haben sie ihr bemerkt dass
wenn sie über skype mit jemandem
kommunizieren der ihnen etwas bedeutet
es ist besser als nichts aber es ist
etwas frustrierend nicht nur weil das
internet ausfallen könnte sondern weil
sie der person nicht in die augen
schauen
der andere grund ist dass sie so genannt
ehrliche signale verlieren
so haben sie sich jetzt gerade nach
vorne gebeugt wenn sie das team passe
ich meine körperhaltung unbewusst an um
ihre haltung nachzuahmen
was die psychologin
was bedeutet es wenn ich mich nach vorne
lehne ich glaube nicht dass es eine
bedeutung hat wir sind soziale wesen die
sich für ein leben in gruppen entwickelt
haben
deshalb verhalten wir uns oft wilden
tiere wir brauchen einander wir
kommunizieren auf nonverbale weises das
beginnt gleich am anfang des lebens sind
sich babys nicht mitteilen können
trotzdem verstehen sie botschaften von
ihren eltern speziell von ihren müttern
und sie übermitteln nonverbale
botschaften
das ist ein thema das ich unser ganzes
leben deshalb wenn sie und ich hier im
studio zusammen sind bestehen einige
dieser sogenannten ehrlichen signale
fort und helfen uns eine flüssigere
unterhaltung zu führen
unter der oberfläche im unterbewusstsein
beeinflussen sie auch die art wie unsere
zellen zum beispiel infektionen
bekämpfen wie schnell tumore wachsen wie
gut wir mit stress umgehen
man weiß zum beispiel dass sport ihm
stil viele physischen kontakt haben die
high fives köpfe zusammenstecken und
umarmungen sport teams mit vielen
derartigen kontakten sind geschlossene
und sie erzielen mehr tore
langfristig sind sie erfolgreicher das
gleiche gilt im geschäftsleben und das
ist extrem wichtig jetzt aber tendieren
wir dazu die digitale kommunikation mit
jener von angesicht zu angesicht zu
verschmelzen weil es einfacher und
billiger ist und das analysieren sie auf
scharfe weise in ihrem buch da schauen
wir in die theorie gleich genauer hinein
ins verstehe ich aber auch sie haben
nicht mein nach vorne lehnen
entschlüsselt sie haben gesagt wir
synchronisieren uns wenn nicht nach
vorne gehen kommen sie auch nach vorne
und das macht einen riesenunterschied
wenn wir physisch anwesend sind also
sind wir physisch anwesend und ihre
forschung hat ja auch einen sehr
physischen aspekt man könnte sagen am
anfang war das dorf und zwar nicht nur
in der menschheitsgeschichte aus der
homo sapiens sesshaft wurde auch am
anfang oder auslöser ihrer überlegungen
und ihre forschung war eine reise in ein
dorf in sizilien habe sogar auf dem
villagran distri xii in sachen
erzählen sie uns was haben sie dort
gemacht sie sind auch nicht alleine
hingegangen glaube ich reiste mit meiner
tochter die gerade die universität
abgeschlossen hatte ich will aber etwas
weiter zurück greifen und ihnen erklären
weshalb mich dieses dorf interessiert
hat ich hatte gerade mein letztes buch
das geschlechter paradox beendet eines
der rätsel auf die ich keine antwort
fand war
warum leben die frauen in allen
industrieländern länger als die männer
warum haben die frauen eine fünf bis
sieben jahre höhere lebenserwartung
einer der gründe die ich entdeckte war
dass frauen im durchschnitt dazu neigen
ihre sozialen kontakte ihr ganzes leben
lang in den vordergrund zu stellen und
zu pflegen sie tendieren dazu
arbeitsplätze zu wählen wo sie mit
anderen menschen kommunizieren und in
verbindung treten können
sie sind diejenigen welche die familien
nach dessen organisieren
weihnachtskarten verschicken die pläne
für nach dessen und kinobesucher mit
freunden machen wenn sie älter werden
wird dies zu einem kritischen faktor für
die gesunderhaltung ihrer denkprozesse
um ihre erinnerung lebendig zu erhalten
und auf ihre gesundheit zu bewahren
weil einige untersuchungen die ich beim
abschluss meines letzten buches
entdeckte zeigen dass menschen die
häufiger ausgehen
die mehr interagieren und es waren vor
allem frauen eine viel längere
lebensdauer hatten und eine bessere
kognitive gesundheit
das veranlasste mich zu einer reise um
herauszufinden wo das nicht der fall ist
wo geschieht das nicht und ich habe vor
in einer vorlesung dass es eine region
gibt wo männer gleich lang leben wie
frauen
nicht nur dass jeder in dieser gegend
eine erhöhte lebensdauer hat
männer haben ein sehr langes leben und
ich beschloss dass ich dorthin muss um
von den wissenschaftlern wie auch von
den hundertjährigen selber zu erfahren
was da geschieht
erfahrung hatte und so als meine
reisebegleiterin und assistentin mit kam
es war sehr gut dass sie mich begleitete
weil diese dörfer einen sehr engen
sozialen zusammenhalt haben
die familie ist extrem wichtig und die
tatsache dass wir als kleine familien
einheit auftraten verlieh uns an orten
glaubwürdigkeit um fremdes nicht zum
schnell akzeptiert werden
eine der spannenden erfahrungen die wir
machten war dass überall wo wir hingehen
um menschen die 100 jahre oder älter
sind zu interviewen
wir hatten ein aufnahmegerät dabei
produzierten eine radio dokumentation
mit dem titel das rätsel der
langlebigkeit
überall wo wir ankamen war der raum
voller leute als wäre seine partei
da war vielleicht die nichte oder der
neffe auf alle fälle die kinder
vielleicht vielleicht schaut der
priester vorbei ein grund dafür war die
neugier auf besucher innen also ich
abgelegenen gegend grund ist aber auch
dass diese alten nie allein gelassen und
dann war es ein vorteil dass sie nicht
als isolierte einsame forscherin dorthin
kamen sondern mit ein bisschen familie
sie erzählen im buch auch die ankunft
als sie von den forschern noch nicht im
dorf ich glaube im hafen oder wo
empfangen wurden erzählen sie kurz dass
das hat sie überrascht auch wie die
kontakte mit den italienischen forschern
sich gestalteten aus nordamerikanischer
sicht war das verblüffend weil die
wissenschaftler und sie in ihren
sozialen kreis einführten als ob wir
ihre sozialen umgebung wären und sie
luden uns nicht nur dazu ein uns ihren
kreis anzuschließen
am ersten abend an dem meine tochter und
ich dort waren wurden wir zum nachtessen
laden an diesem nach dessen namen nicht
nur die wissenschaftler teil
ein genetischer ein demograf ein arzt
sondern auch ihre freundin in einem fall
war auch der schwager dabei es war ein
sehr großer tisch mit vielen soziale
interaktion und man gab uns das gefühl
sehr willkommen zu sein
von meinem hintergrund her weiß ja
ungewöhnlich einem besucher so zu machen
sie brachten uns auch persönlich in die
so genannte saudische blaue zone die
blaue zone ist die abgelegene gegend im
südosten der insel
sie fuhren mit uns am nächsten tag
dorthin sie begleiteten uns ging mit uns
mittagessen um uns persönlich unsere
übersetzer vorzustellen und sicher zu
sein dass alles in ordnung ist
das ist eine total andere einstellung
wie man andere menschen behandelt wie
man soziale bildung herstellt und es war
spannend wenn es ein gutes beispiel ist
warum menschen in diesem teil sardiniens
warum es dort zehnmal so viele über
hundertjährige gibt wie im übrigen
europa oder in nordamerika sechsmal so
viele gibt wie auf dem italienischen
festland das nur 120 kilometer entfernt
ist
ich glaube dieser warme empfang und die
art wie sie menschen in ihrem sozialen
kreis behandeln ist ein wichtiger
anhaltspunkt um zu verstehen nicht nur
weshalb sie so lange leben
dafür gibt es einen biochemischen grund
sondern warum man ein so langes leben
haben möchte wenn wir es oder sie es in
einer schlagzeile sagen müssten mal wir
werden dann schon präziser wieder warum
leben die so lang es ist schwierig diese
frage mit einem satz beantworten
ich würde sagen soweit wir wissen gibt
es eine reihe von gründen weshalb sie so
lange leben 25 prozent ihrer
langlebigkeit wird auf genetische
faktoren zurückgeführt
75 prozent ihrer langlebigkeit auf ihren
lebensstil dazu gehört ihre betätigung
weil sie sehr aktive leben im freien
führten sie waren hirten und bauern und
sie kletterten auf hügel und wieder
hinunter während einem großteil ihres
arbeitslebens
sie blieben aktiv bis über 90 hinaus
einer der männer die ich im buch
porträtiere hat mit 105 ein wildschwein
erlegt und er war immer noch zu fuß
unterwegs kanadischen maßstäben ist das
sehr ungewöhnlich würde ich sagen das
sind einige gründe die ernährung ist ein
punkt aber ich würde sagen zu diesen
faktoren des lebensstils kommt hinzu
dass es in diesen darf an einen enormen
sozialen zusammenhalt gibt und sie
soziale unterstützung erhalten
und ich möchte etwas ganz wichtiges
hinzufügen wenn wir an soziale
unterstützung denken denken wir oft nur
an die paar leute die uns nahe stehen
das ist aber nicht der dorf effekt der
village effekt sowohl in den saudischen
dörfern wie in der metapher die ich in
diesem buch benutze schließt auch die
mittleren und entfernteren kontakte in
ihrer gemeinde 1 die leute denen sie in
ihrem leben täglich begegnen das könnte
der mann sein bei dem sie seit 25 oder
30 jahren die zeitung kaufen und mit dem
sie tag für tag eine kurze unterhaltung
führen
es könnte sein dass sie zu der person
bei der sie ihre lebensmittel kaufen
eine beziehung haben
es könnte auf der post sein was ich im
dorf bemerkte weil alles so eng vernetzt
war
jeder kannte jeden und diese forschung
sagt uns das ist ein sehr wichtiger
grund weshalb menschen alt werden es
gibt 151 langzeitstudien die uns sagen
dass diejenigen die ein integriertes
sozialleben haben das heißt nicht nur
ihre frau nicht nur ihr bester freund
aber ihre entfernteren kontakte in der
gemeinde die sie kennen führen zu einer
höheren lebenserwartung in der tat gibt
es eine 91 prozentige wahrscheinlichkeit
dass sie länger leben als ihre einsame
nacht also zwei drei vertrauenspersonen
reiche nicht dass sich diese
langlebigkeit nicht der natur dann von
meinem umfeld bekomme sie haben fotos
mitgebracht aus dem dorf in sardinien
und eines zeigt sie haben ja alle so
glaube ich okay dann genannt gehörte das
zur persönlichen begegnung
wir sehen hier einen mann der wenn ich
mal so sagen darf nicht so wahnsinnig
glücklich aussieht also heißt das
täuscht das bild oder ist das ein einer
der sehr alt geworden ist über 100 wer
ist es wie alt ist er und ist eher
unglücklich das ist 101 jahre alter mann
der mit seiner nichte leben sie sehen
sie gleich über ihn und seine
grossnichte kam vorbei um essen zu
bringen
während wir dort waren kamen viele
besucher bei diesem mann war wirklich
spannend dass ihr die vorstellung es
brauche positives denken um gesund zu
bleiben und ein langes leben zu haben
ins licht rückt
er war der griesgrämige gramm dickste
mann den ich je getroffen habe
er verweigerte auf viele meiner fragen
die antwort erwählte mich mehr oder
weniger an
ich fragte ihn was erklärt ihr langes
leben und er sagte sinngemäß das geht
sie nichts an
ich sagte glauben sie es ist der
wunderbare saudische wein der kann den
ihr hier trinkt von dem manche sagen
ein restaurator spezielle auswahl 100
und er sagte ich genieße man wein etwas
zu sehen im wesentlichen widerspiegelt
sein verhalten das nicht sehr einladend
nicht sehr glücklich war aber
tatsächlich die forschen und die
forschung sagt uns dass es nicht ein
positives verhalten ist das zu
gesundheit und langem leben führt
wischen sie damit nicht die akzente der
positiven psychologie vom tisch das ist
doch sind positiv wie gut also gut und
so das würde helfen stimmt nicht
bestimmt nicht für die forschung darüber
wie lange sie leben wenn sie zum
beispiel ein pessimist sieht es gibt
keinen grund weshalb das eine einfluss
haben sollte
es gibt sogar forschung wie sagt
pessimismus habe einen positiven effekt
weil sie so zielstrebig sind und so viel
arbeit investieren in alles was es
braucht für ein langes leben
allerdings fiel mir bei ihm nicht nur
seine grantiger persönlichkeit auf
sondern die tatsache dass den ganzen
nachmittag über leute kamen um essen zu
bringen und nach ihm zu sehen
der enorme respekt den seine nichte
entgegenbrachte sie nannte ihn gelte so
mein schatz obschon er ein eher
schwieriger mann war es war wirklich
einen kontrast zumindest zu der art und
weise wie wir in nordamerika unserer
alten behandeln wo der kommentiert
george burns sagte glücks bedeutet eine
große eng verbundene glückliche familie
zu haben die weit weg in einer anderen
stadt lebt dort trifft das nicht zu
und ich glaube das hat einen großen
einfluss auf die zusätzlichen jahre die
diese menschen haben
aber um diesen sardischen bergdorf kein
unrecht zu tun wollen wir sagen sie
haben dann auch viele begegnungen gehabt
wie mit diesem ziel
wer war es josef oder oder der wird sehr
fröhlich waren viele dieser über
hundertjährigen auch richtig erfüllt vom
leben und glücklich
ich möchte über das reiche leben
sprechen dass auf alle 100 jährigen die
ich getroffen habe zutrifft
viele von ihnen hatten auch ein sehr
hartes leben sie arbeiteten viele
stunden
viele von ihnen erwarten vor
sonnenaufgang gingen zu fuß zu ihren
weit entfernten feldern
sie hatten gemessen an unseren standards
nicht die lebensqualität die wir im
westen genießen was sie aber hatten war
ein enormes maß an sozialer
unterstützung und sozialer bindung
das bild das sie hier sehen die uci vor
seinen beiden söhnen die gekommen waren
um nach ihm zu sehen
diese männer diese knackigen jungen
männer sind in ihren siebzigern
stellen sie sich vor nach ihren eltern
zu sehen wenn sie 75 76 77 jahre alt
sind
das ist ein interessantes konzept aber
nicht nur die frauen tun es sind frauen
und männer
und es gehört zum normalen leben dass
sie sich bei der arbeit frei nehmen um
nach ihren alten eltern zu sehen was
dabei wirklich interessant ist gerade
heute morgen erhielt ich eine e mail zu
einem artikel in der new york times
wonach es eine neue untersuchung gibt
betreffend die nationen mit den höchsten
ratings im glücksindex und was der
wichtigste faktor für glück sein
es war das einkommen pro kopf der
bevölkerung also wie wohlhabend leute
sind was für finanzielle
wahlmöglichkeiten sie haben nummer zwei
waren soziale unterstützung und
beziehungen
das unglaubliche daran ist hier mag es
sich um ein traditionelles dorf handeln
wir sprechen aber von globalen
vergleichen länder auf der ganzen welt
manche sind ärmer mancher reicher manche
mehr entwickelt anderer weniger
ausschlaggebend ist dass diese soziale
unterstützung einem uni
selon bedürfnis entspricht nicht nur für
ein langes leben sondern auch für glück
also das ist ja die kernthese in ihrem
buch gute soziale beziehungen lassen uns
länger und gesünder leben ist die
kausalität damit schon nachgewiesen ich
habe gesehen es gibt ja auch ein paar
andere beispiele ikaria die insel in der
ägäis griechen werden sie auch so halt
und dort sagt man ja das ist vielleicht
der kaffee also kann man beweisen dass
ist der soziale zusammenhalt ist der das
langlebige fördern
ich glaube die griechische insel ikaria
hat ein sehr ähnliches soziales umfeld
die studie zu ikaria aber einfach noch
nicht publiziert als ich einen teil
meiner recherchen und reisen fur das
buch machte sie kam später heraus aber
sie haben recht viele der studien die
wir haben sind langzeituntersuchung das
heißt sie messen alles über eine
bevölkerungsgruppe und dann warten sie
das ist faszinierend auch wenn es keine
ursachenforschung ist
sie können nicht leute in zwei gruppen
unterteilen die einen haben soziale
kontakte die andere nicht das wäre
ethisch nicht vertretbar
mit ihren können sie das machen darauf
kommt es gleich was aber interessant ist
wenn sie eine ganze bevölkerungsgruppe
nehmen sie über eine zeitspanne
begleiten und alles über ihren
lebensstil erfassen
sie müssen wie schwer die leute sind ob
sie verheiratet sind wie viel sie
trinken was sie essen und ob sie gegen
grippe geimpft wurden und wenn sie eine
herzkrankheit hatten
ob sie kardiologische rehabilitierung
erhielten wie oft sie das haus verlassen
und leute treffen wie viel soziale
unterstützung sie haben ob sie arbeiten
oder nicht ob sie geschieden sind
wenn sie all diese faktoren in einer
großen population berücksichtigen
wer überlebt am ende welcher faktor ist
entscheidend um vorauszusagen wie er
nach sagen die sieben zehn jahren noch
das was wir diese zwei faktoren
entscheidender als training gewicht
sogar als das rauchen von zigaretten
nämlich ihre sozialen bindungen ihre
namen kontakte und ihre soziale
integration das heißt wie oft sie
hinausgehen und am gemeinschaftsleben
teilnehmen es kann fast alles seien zum
beispiel ein buch in kanada spielen
männer oft ein leben lang als ok und sie
haben ihre gruppe mit der sie hockey
spielen und danach gehen sie ein bier
trinken
es kann partizipation bei der arbeit
sein solange sie leute treffen
engagement in der gemeinde oder
freiwilligenarbeit
ich bin überzeugt dies ist auch ein
grund weshalb kirchgänger leute die sich
religiös engagieren
oft ebenfalls gesünder sind und länger
leben was sie sich mindestens einmal pro
woche in einer sozialen umgebung bewegen
sie sehen ihre gemeinschaft und haben
teil und sie kümmern sich um andere
leute von der soziale neurowissenschaft
wissen wir dass das eine enorme wirkung
hat damit belegt das buch ja etwas was
aristoteles vor über 2000 jahren gesagt
hat der mensch ist ein von politikern
ein lebewesen das in der police in der
gemeinschaft nur zufrieden leben kann
hat es übrigens leute gegeben die gesagt
haben das ist ja gar nicht neu was sie
uns hier schreiben das hat das his
daughter s und die alten französischen
soziologen mit an ihm als sozial und so
da haben die alles auch schon gewusst
dass gar nichts neues drin
es stimmt und es stimmt nicht was stimmt
es dass viele der alten philosophen
einige zentrale war reisen erfassten die
auf uns heute immer noch zu treffen
wirklich neu ist aber dass wir nun die
werkzeuge haben es zu beweisen
aristoteles hatte diese werkzeuge nicht
konnte sich nur auf selbstbeobachtung
stützen
wir aber haben magnetresonanztomografie
jetzt gibt es blutuntersuchung die uns
zeigen welche auswirkungen ein streit
mit ihrem ehepartner auf ihre blut
cortisol werte und ihre oxytocin
wir können zb den unterschied zeigen
zwischen jemanden der daheim im
wohnzimmer eine sendung wie diese hier
schaut und jemanden der in einem labor
interagiert in einem
magnetresonanztomographen welche
unterschiedlichen bereiche des gehirns
werden aktiviert
neu ist also die wissenschaft die uns
sagt dass unsere beziehungen einen
direkten sicht und messbaren einfluss
auf unseren person das ist die eine
neuigkeit und total aktuell und neu sind
die demographischen untersuchungen der
uns zeigen wie wichtig das ist für
gesundheit glück und das lernen über das
lernen haben wir noch gar nicht
gesprochen
sie wissen gibt es einen großen trend in
richtung digitalisierung nicht nur am
arbeitsplatz sondern auch im schulzimmer
tatsächlich gibt es aber weniger
hinweise für den erfolg dieser
bestrebungen als für die wirkung
zwischenmenschlicher kontakte auf das
lernen und erinnern
also haben wir wieder diese these ihre
starke überzeugung das macht einfach ein
unterschied ob elektronik dazwischen ist
und telekommunikation oder ob er von
mensch zu mensch kommunizieren wie wir
es als spezies seite 100.000 jahren
machen oder so wir darum aus asien sind
schauen wir uns jetzt genau an wie ihr
beziehungsnetz aussieht damit begehe ich
keine indiskretion weil sie haben in
ihrem buch auf zeichnen drucken lassen
wir sehen also dass soziogramm von susan
pinker wenn ich richtig gezählt habe
haben sie etwa 40 personen da um sich
herum und ich habe gelesen die hohe
kreise sind frauen und die dreiecke sind
männer stimmt dass 40 menschen bilden
ihr beziehungsnetz das stimmt aber es
handelt sich hier nicht um ein
erweitertes soziales netzwerk werden
alle leute erfasste ich kenne und mit
denen ich regelmäßig kontakt habe werden
es etwa 150 für das buch werde ich ein
kleineres soziogramm um zwei dinge zu
beweisen
dieses buch ist nicht nur über
wissenschaft sondern auch über
geschichten von menschen die mich
berührt haben
die bei mir nach klappt deshalb schrieb
ich nicht nur über die leute die ich in
sardinien getroffen habe wie schrieb
über menschen aus meinem eigenen leben
im sozialraum dass sie hier sehen stehen
die dunklen punkte für menschen die im
buch porträtiert werden
es ist ein buch über
sozialwissenschafter seiner beliebt wird
durch geschichten von wirklichen
menschen die mir begegnet sind die die
leute berühren weil sie mich bloß ein
weiterer grund ist in bezug auf die
sozialen netzwerke gibt es einen
unterschied zwischen den geschlechtern
als ich mit dem buch begann wenig davon
aus dass frauen besser integrierte
größere soziale netzwerke haben dass
männer und dass dies einer der gründe
sein weshalb sie länger leben
das stimmt nicht frauen neigen eher zu
dichterin engeren sozialen netzwerken
und männern zu größeren mit eher
schwächeren bindungen
deshalb sieht man oft dass männer in
umgebungen die dem militär erfolgreich
sind oder in großen unternehmen wo sie
tausend kontakte in ihrer elektronischen
kartei haben die dicken striche sind
nahe beziehungen und die fein striche
sind schwache week links schwache
beziehungen was ist und sie ist ja ganz
viele auf der linken seite des ozeans
ganz viele starke beziehung was heißt
wie definieren sie eine starke beziehung
eine starke beziehung ist jemand den ich
regelmäßig treffe und mit dem ich
regelmäßig von angesicht zu angesicht
kommuniziere und der für mich da ist
wenn ich ihn brauche wenn ich mir 200
franken
müsste oder sie zu wem würden sie gehen
ich bin sicher sie haben in diesem
fernsehsender viele kontakte aber sie
würden nicht unbedingt jemanden von hier
um ein darlehen bitten
wer würde ihnen eine suppe bringen wenn
sie sich nicht gut fühlen
wer würde sie zu einem arzttermin
begleiten oder sie abholen nach sagen
wir einen zahnärztlichen eingriff das
sind die engen bindungen die schwächeren
bindungen die sie sehen wie sie
bemerkten sind das dünne gestrichen
diese sind wichtig auch wenn sie nicht
da sind um sie aufzurichten
wenn sie sich schlecht fühlen oder
niedergeschlagen sind trotzdem haben
auch sie eine wichtige rolle zu spielen
sagt uns die wissenschaft spannend ist
untersuchungen zeigen dass beide arten
von bindung rückläufig sind in den 1980
er jahren als sehr wenige von uns
netzwerkgeräte besaßen vielleicht
niemand außer den wissenschaftlern
hatten wir im durchschnitt drei menschen
auf die wir zählen konnten jetzt da
jeder ein smartphone besitzt haben wir
einen durchschnitt von weniger als 2 und
manche leute haben jemanden auf den sie
zählen können und auf die schwächeren
bindungen werden weniger wegen unserem
heutigen lebensstil viele von uns
arbeiten zurückgezogen wir kaufen bei
amazon ein beziehen unsere lebensmittel
online unsere bücher online die orte wo
wir zufällig leute trafen verschwinden
es ist als ob jemand die gehsteige von
den straßen entfernen würde und wir
werden als individuen viel stärker
isoliert heute haben wir eine
epidemische einsamkeit was paradox ist
weil wir angeblich in einem globalen
dorf leben nicht wahr
wir sind angeblich alle miteinander
verbunden
tatsache ist aber dass die einsamkeit
zunimmt und darüber zu sprechen ist ein
tabu und auch noch eine detailfrage die
linien gehen ja auch zwischen den
individuen hin und her heißt dass das
zeigt wie ihre bekannten unter
da wieder verlinkt vernetzt sind ist es
wichtig in einer verschworenen einem
knäuel zu sein oder ist es egal ob ich
einfach 150 leute kenne die sich nicht
kennen
dieser aspekt der verlorenheit den sie
aufgreifen ist extrem wichtig das ist
mit ein grund weshalb ich die metapher
vom dorf welt sagen wir ich kenne den
lebensmittelhändlern und mein sohn kennt
ihn aus und wir kennen auch eine vierte
person und wir sind alle untereinander
verbunden
diese art von verwobenen netzwerken
haben die stärkste wirkung auf uns hier
gibt es einen kleinen vorbehalt
psychisch und physisch sind diese
verwobenen netzwerke wirklich gut für
uns weniger hilfreich sind sie wenn es
um ein vorwärtskommen in der karriere
geht es ist wichtig dass auf einen
justiert zu betrachten wenn sie in ihrer
karriere vorwärts kommen wollen ist es
wirklich wichtig sowohl schwacher wie
auch starke bindungen zu haben weil die
schwachen bindungen informationen bieten
die ihr enges netzwerk nicht hat das
wurde von marc kronawetter untersucht
einem sozialwissenschaftler in
kalifornien der die kraft vom schwachen
bindungen aufzeigte dass leute die die
soziale leiter aufsteigen weniger stark
verknüpfte bindungen haben
ich glaube das ist die stärke von linke
den oder facebook zumindest am anfang
von facebook dass es ihnen diese
schwächeren verbindung ermöglicht die
kehrseite davon ist dass diese
schwächeren verbindungen nicht durch die
engen und mittleren verbindungen die
sich hier sehen ersetzt werden können
nur schon weil sie mir keine 200 franken
ausleihen wenn ich die brauche brauche
ich meinen armen leute ist das buch auch
ein bisschen ein buch besonders über die
verhältnisse in nordamerika sie leben in
montreal in kanada aber in den staaten
vielleicht noch mehr wo die dörfer
wirklich weg sind nur noch ein
einkaufszentrum wo man nicht lange
bleibt nicht mal im coffeeshop da
überhaupt nicht forschung und
wissenschaft sind heute international
und ein großteil der forschung die ich
zitiere ist nicht nur europäische
forschung sondern aus diesem teil
europas deutschland die schweiz und die
skandinavischen länder verfügen über ein
wirklich starkes forschungsnetzwerk in
sozialer neurowissenschaft für mich ein
glücksfall
das kommt überall diese diese trends
gelten überall also weit herum
ja ich glaube es ist wichtig zu erwähnen
dass es geringe unterschiede gehabt
allerdings weniger zwischen nationen als
unterschiede zwischen der art von
umgebung in der man lebt wenn sie zb in
einer sehr eng verwobenen kleinen
gemeinde leben werden sie eher von
diesen vorteilen profitieren als in
einer schlafstadt einer exakt wie man
sie in den usa nennt wenn sie etwa in
arizona oder texas leben wo sie ein
riesiges grundstück haben in ihr auto
einsteigen und von ihrer garage zur
arbeit fahren und am feierabend fahren
sie nach hause in ihre garage
sie bereiten ihr nach dessen zu
überwachen die hausaufgaben ihrer kinder
und ihr einziger sozialer kontakt ist im
internet das trifft auf immer mehr
menschen in allen industrieländern zu
sie stehen unter zeitdruck und sie
machen den fehler zu denken dass das ein
guter ersatz sei oder das oder das
worauf ich hinweisen möchte das ist mir
wirklich wichtig ich bin keine
technologie ich glaube es geht um den
unterschied zwischen junkfood und
biologischer lokaler hausgemachter
nahrung die sie gemeinsam mit ihrer
familie und mit ihren freunden genießen
digitale kommunikation macht sinn hat
eine wichtige rolle in der logistik um
treffen zu koordinieren um sehr konkrete
einzelne formen von informationen zu
kommunizieren
da ist digitale kommunikation sind sms
gut aber um vertrauen aufzubauen um
komplexe probleme zu lösen um dieses
gefühl der zugehörigkeit aufzubauen was
ein grundlegendes menschliches bitte
office ist wie essen und trinken
schlafen wie sex dafür müssen wir alle
fühlen
dass wir dazugehören aus der forschung
wissen wir dass unsere online netzwerke
das nicht bieten
es gibt schon kritiker auch eine
kritikerin die ich gefunden habe die
schreiben sie seien eine maschinen
stürmerin
sie rebellierten gegen die moderne zeit
ärgert sie das wenn die leute wenn sie
mit neuen ideen kommen gibt es immer
leute die darauf reagieren
ich würde niemals sagen wir sollen
unsere geräte in den müll werfen
ich bin genauso abhängig von meinem
mobiltelefon wie alle anderen
zwei meiner drei kinder leben weit weg
und wir kommunizieren auf viele
verschiedene arten mit unseren
mobiltelefonen mit sms und e mail und
per telefon und wir besuchen
ich finde es ist wichtig dass wir nicht
vergessen immer wenn etwas neues und
glänzendes kommt besonders wenn es sich
um ein objekt handelt verlieben wir uns
oft so wie wir uns zum beispiel ins auto
verliebten und wir können nicht
voraussehen welche nachteile es gibt wir
lieben unsere geräte auch ich liebe sie
aber wichtig ist zu benennen was wir
aufgeben was geben wir auf und sie sagen
für die logistik ist das gut wir
organisieren uns aber am schluss ist
wichtig dass er physisch face to face
zusammenkommen
ich nehme zwar das beispiel einer person
die schon lange als single lebt und
einen partner oder eine partnerin finden
möchte vielleicht sogar heiraten möchte
kann man nicht sagen das internet ist
eine wunderbare fundgrube weil jetzt
habe ich plötzlich potenziell sieben
milliarden menschen wo ich meinen traum
finden kann
an prinzessin den traumprinzen stellen
sie das internet nicht am besten so
negativ ist es nicht auch eine chance
für ganz nahe
wichtige glück spenden die dinge im
leben
ich würde sagen es bietet die
möglichkeit menschen zu treffen die sich
außerhalb ihres unmittelbaren physischen
raums befinden
also ja es ist eine möglichkeit und ich
bin nicht dagegen aber es gibt absolut
keinen hinweis darauf dass es besser ist
dass der zufall es gibt keine
wissenschaftlich und sagt dass es besser
funktioniert aus der zufall
ich finde jede gelegenheit die ihnen
ermöglicht ihren lebenspartner zu
treffen ist großartig aber ich glaube
das enorme vertrauen dass wir in diese
geräte haben ist fehlgeleitet
vor allem weil sich leute online anders
präsentieren können als sie in
wirklichkeit sind zb ich sehe sie
persönlich sehe gewisse seiten von ihnen
sie nehmen kontakt auf sie haben keine
angst mich anzuschauen wenn ich mit
ihnen sprechen ließen sie sie zeigen mir
dass sie verstehen wenn sie sich aber
online präsentieren könnten sie eine
sehr andere person seien sich aber so
darstellen
und wenn sie sich einige der
altmodischen begriffe anschauen die wir
für romantische anziehungskraft brauchen
da sprechen wir über chemie wir sprechen
von einem gefühl der anziehungskraft
das kann online nicht erfasst wird
einerseits würde ich sagen wenn es für
sie funktioniert ist es großartig vor
allem für leute die zum beispiel an
einem abgelegenen ort leben oder die zu
schüchtern sind um auszugehen und leute
in einem sozialen umfeld zu treffen
aber ich glaube es ist weniger
erfolgreich als die leute berichten und
wir haben noch keine informationen
darüber wie lange diese beziehungen
halten wir müssen warten und schauen
grundsätzlich schreiben sie im buch die
ehe ist eine formidable art das leben
auch zu verlängern das ist einer dieser
faktoren der macht das die leute
glücklicher und gesünder leben aber sie
sagen das nicht bewiesen dass das
internet wo man algorithmisch gar nicht
doch meinen
fressen aufschreiben und so das glauben
sie nicht dass das hier einen großen
gewinn gebracht hat dass die menschen
glücklicher sich weltweit ehelichen
können lassen sie mich als erstes
korrigieren
ja die ehe ist wichtig für ein langes
leben und glück aber nur eine gute
insbesondere für frauen
es gibt einen unterschied zwischen den
geschlechtern männer leben praktisch auf
der ganzen welt länger wenn sie
verheiratet sind und wenn sie getrennt
und entschieden werden oder verwitweten
hat das einen direkten einfluss auf ihre
gesundheit was wir den witwer effekt
nennen
interessant ist dass die ehe für frauen
schlecht ist wenn es viele konflikte
gibt
für männer ist die ehe ganz allgemein
besser für frauen ist es besser als
nicht verheiratet zu sein
eine schlechte ehe wirkt sich bei frauen
aber auf ihren schlaf aus auf ihre
chronischen schmerzen
es gibt also ich glaube die frage war
wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe ob
das internet hilft uns zu verpaaren
richtig und ob wir dadurch länger leben
war das ihre frage falls das geschieht
und wenn es geschieht ist es für alle
wunderbar ich finde aber die leute
müssten etwas kritischer sein was die
fähigkeit von digitalen geräten
anbelangt entscheide zu fällen
ich benutze sie noch einmal aus meinem
beispiel haben sie etwas dagegen
ich kann eine liste von einzelnen
faktoren für die anforderungen an einen
potenziellen partner zusammenstellen
es könnte heißen er muss mindestens 160
cm groß gut angezogen sein muss sich für
fotografie interessieren muss ja
ordentlich und organisiert sein muss
musik mögen usw usw
realität ist aber wenn wir die forschung
über ehen und erfolgreiche romantische
beziehungen anschauen dass die menschen
nicht sehr gut darin sind zu
quantifizieren
was sie an einem partner ansieht diese
konkreten dinge sind keine voraussage
für eine gute beziehung was ein gutes
paar auszeichnet ist ob sie da sind für
mich wenn ich sie brauche kann ich mich
auf sie verlassen kritisieren sie meine
kochkunst machen sie kompromisse um mit
meiner mutter zurecht zu kommen
wenn wir ein krankes kind haben sind sie
da um mich und die familie zu
unterstützen
das sind die dinge die es für eine lange
beziehung braucht nicht ob der mann zum
beispiel so groß ist oder ob es so viel
geld verdient und das würde er im oder
sie im internet ja auch nicht ehrlich
ankreuzen vielleicht diese anderen
wichtigen fragen die ich verstehe den
gedanken und jetzt wo sie gesagt haben
dass es einen riesigen unterschied liegt
wie männer und frauen ihre ehen werten
und gewichten
gib mir das eine gute gelegenheit ihnen
zu sagen dass ich ihr buch ihr neues
buch the village effekt ein bisschen
gelesen habe wie das geschlechter
paradox 2.0 also das frühere buch das
sie geschrieben haben die öl das viel
staub aufgewirbelt hat dass frauen eben
ganz anders sind und darum im
berufsleben auch andere ziele haben als
männer
da habe ich gesagt das ist ein bisschen
der geschlechter paradox 2.0 weil auch
wenn man jetzt sieht wie männer und
frauen mit dem computer umgehen und mit
den social media
da ist es auch wieder ganz anders zuerst
hat sich der sturm der staub gelegt den
sie auf gewerbe- und haben oder werden
sie noch angegriffen wegen dem früheren
buch geschlechter box es geht nicht
darum angegriffen zu werden sondern dass
ich mich einer neuen thema zuwenden
obschon es zwischen den beiden büchern
eine verbindung gibt am anfang stand die
frage weshalb frauen länger leben
nicht alle frauen
aber im durchschnitt ein grund ist weil
sie dazu neigen ihre sozialen bindungen
in den vordergrund zu stellen und sie
extrem wichtig zu finden damit fing ich
an
aber dieses buch village effekt wurde
viel breiter in diesem buch geht es
eigentlich nicht um die kluft zwischen
den geschlechtern
ich steckte ein geschlechterunterschiede
auf aber das war mehr ein unternehmer
und nicht das hauptthema aber ich war
jetzt doch eine these auch im neuen buch
gilt vermutlich ihrer ansicht nach ich
spitze jetzt wirklich zu männer sind
lausige kommunikatoren und statistisch
gesehen nicht jeder aber und frauen sind
begnadete kommunikator innen und das
hängt mich auch noch aus ihrem früheren
buch mich erinnere gelesen zu haben mit
dem testosteron zusammen das testosteron
eines der haupt hormone der männer macht
uns zu schlechten kommunikatoren das ist
dann interessanter punkt aber ich würde
sagen
noch wichtiger ist wenn sie in etwas gut
werden wollen nehmen wir an sie wollen
ein großartiger tennisspieler werden
im moment bin ich wirklich schlecht aber
wenn ich eine gute tennisspielerin
werden will muss ich nicht nur stunden
nehmen
ich beobachte auch die lehrmeister und
ich habe sie nach für jede fähigkeit und
soziale fähigkeiten sind eine kompetenz
wie andere auch als frauen zum beispiel
am arbeitsplatz aufsteigen und
erfolgreich sein wollten orientierten
sie sich an männlichen vorbildern
sie sagten was tun männer damit sie die
vorstandsebene erreicht ins chefbüro
gekommen
ich verhalte mich ebenso ich denke das
war eine ausgezeichnete strategie für
diese zeit jetzt aber drehe ich das
ganze um und sage männer wollt ihr nicht
länger und glücklicher leben wenn ja
schaut ihr besser was eure frauen tun
weil eure frauen die dinge sehr viel
anders angehen rasiert eure frauen laden
leute zum nachtessen
sie bleiben mit ihren freunden und der
familie in kontakt sie nehmen sich zeit
für leute vielleicht müssten mehr von
euch das ebenfalls tun
denn das ist der schlüssel für ein
längeres leben aber damals
da müsste meine antwort doch sein ich
habe meinen testosteron und das macht
dass ich ein tunnelblick habe um eine
karriere verfolgen will
wie können sie als wissenschaftlerin und
biologisch argumentieren der psychologin
von mir verlangen dass ich an meinen
hormonen vorbei mich auf neue
kommunikations felder begeben alles auf
die hormone zurückzuführen ist ein sehr
simplifizieren das argument ich bringe
dieses argument weder in diesem noch im
ersten buch ich sage dass wir nun
aktuelle und neue fakten haben die wir
den digitalen instrumenten verdanken den
biologischen methoden und den
bildgebenden verfahren für das gehirn
die uns zeigen wie wichtig persönliche
menschliche kontakte sind jetzt wo wir
diese information haben was machen wir
damit es ist das würden wir sagen was
tatsächlich geschieht wir haben
informationen dass unsere autos die
ozonschicht beeinträchtigen
unternehmen wir etwas dagegen
oder machen wir einfach nichts jetzt da
wir informationen haben
aus internationaler großer und breit
angelegter forschung meta analysen die
uns sagen wie wichtig das ist machen wir
einfach weiter wie bisher und isolieren
uns immer mehr oder fangen wir damit an
diese neuen informationen in unseren
lebensstil einzubauen wie zb als wer
etwa vor einer generation herausfanden
dass ständiges sitzen uns nicht so gut
da dass es nicht so gut war uns
fettreich und 20 zu ernähren und keine
bewegung zu haben
wir veränderten unsere gewohnheiten das
resultat
insbesondere männer konnten ihre
lebensdauer verlängern als sie ungefähr
so alt waren wie ich heute waren zb
viele freunde meiner eltern bereits zu
viele freunde meines vaters waren
bereits an einer herzkrankheit gestorben
aber heute meine männlichen freunde sie
wandern sie fahren rad sika jacken und
sind in bester gesundheit im gleichen
alter
so haben wir in einer generation einiges
verändert ich meine ewig können wir
nicht leben was ich sage lasst uns
dieses modell nun auf menschliche
kommunikation und interaktion übertragen
wir wissen dass es einen unterschied
macht wenn wir uns von angesicht zu
angesicht treffen
es gibt eine neue untersuchung so neu
dass sie nicht einmal im buch erwähnt
wird die zeigt dass drei faktoren ihre
lebenserwartung um 30 prozent reduzieren
wenn sie allein leben wenn sie sich oft
einsam fühlen und nun kommt der wirklich
spannende punkt wenn sie oft zeit mit
sich allein verbringen egal ob sie in
ton oder extrovertiert sind wenn sie auf
zeit alleine verbringen wird ihre
lebenserwartung 30 prozent kürzer sein
als bei jemand anderem
selbst der eigenbrötler der sagt ich
fühle mich wohler an meinem computer und
lass mir eine pizza kommen ich gehe
nicht gerne unter die leute die quasi
mit mir die ohren fall gilt es auch wenn
einer gerne allein zu hause ist ist es
auch ungesund für ihn ja und das ist
einer der schlüsse aus informationen dem
verlauf des schreibens zusammengekommen
sind
ich gebe ihren zuschauern einen einblick
in den schreibprozess ich schrieb am
beruf und meine verlegerin notierte am
rahmen sie korrigiert immer noch auf
papier kopien was ist mit mir ich bin
introvertiert muss ich ebenfalls
hinausgehen das schickte mich auf eine
breit angelegte sondierung über
introvertierte und extrovertiert
dabei fand ich heraus dass
introvertierte genau wie extrovertierte
sich häufiger erkälten wenn sie keine
sozialen kontakte haben sie erholen sich
weniger schnell von erkältungen ihre
tumore wachsen
im wesentlichen geht es um biologie es
ist wie wenn man sagen würde ich bin
eine kleine person er ist groß deshalb
muss er essen während ich überhaupt
keine nahrung braucht ist dass ich eine
schlechte nachricht jetzt müssen die
armen introvertierten neben dem jogging
dass sie machen sollten eine diät hin
und wieder etwas und die auch noch
solche reisen das wird das nichts ist
nicht ein paradox sei sozial sei nett
miteinander ist das nicht komisch ich
würde sagen ich komme in einen ethischen
konflikt wenn man seine freunde bloß als
instrumente betrachtet ich treffe dich
damit ich durchschnittlich fünf jahre
länger leben
es geht mir eigentlich gar nicht um dich
aber die meisten leute gehen nicht so
mit ihren beziehungen um die meisten
leute sind in ihren beziehungen
engagiert ich glaube der fehler ist
nicht dass man seine freunde und seine
familie mit joggen gleichsetzt oder mit
dem schlucken von vitaminen
das ist ein fehler weil die wirkung der
beziehung gleichzeitig auch die
bedeutung ist die sie für ihr leben hat
nicht wahr
ich will zum schluss genau ich will zum
schluss noch einmal ihren sehr
kritischen blick auf das internet
hinterfragen und zwar das buch beginnt
mit dem beispiel eines rockmusikers da
ist etwa 50 und erfährt wenn er keinen
ihre bekommt innerhalb von ein paar
monaten ist tot und es gibt fast keinen
ihren aber hat so viele freunde und ein
so gutes netz wie es geschrieben haben
er bekommt vier drei oder vier angebote
und überlebt jetzt habe ich einen
artikel gefunden jeff jarvis internet
guru einer der das neue netz liebt und
der sagt ein bisschen das gegenteil der
sagt erhard prostata krebs bekommen und
hat sofort einen blog geschrieben hat
der ganzen welt zeugs mitgeteilt dass
wir vielleicht die welt gar nicht wissen
wollten
das nachlassen seiner manneskraft hat
alles ausgelegt aus überzeugung und sagt
und dann hat sich ein freund gemeldet
denen ich nicht mehr kannte und der hat
mir sehr geholfen könnte nicht auch oft
das gegenteil wahr sein dass die neuen
technologien kommunikationsformen
helfen uns dann auch im richtigen leben
länger zu leben
ich glaube das stimmt auch wenn es eine
echte persönliche beziehung entfacht das
fantastische am internet ist der
austausch von informationen und ich
glaube das ist was sie hier meinen und
viele leute die krank sind nutzen ist
dafür
sie können online communitys bilden und
sich austauschen ich finde das großartig
weil geografische grenzen keine rolle
spielen aber für die art von kontakt
über die ich spreche müssen sie einen
schritt weiter gehen das heißt wenn sie
im internet einen freund finden machen
sie einen plan diese person zu treffen
schauen sie ob er wirklich jene ist der
zu sein er behauptet bauen sie eine
beziehung auf zu dieser person
das geniale am internet ist es spielt
keine rolle dass ich in monza erlebe und
sie in zürich wenn wir gemeinsame
interessen oder situationen haben können
wir uns über internet verbinden wir
können informationen austauschen
wir können aber auch einen schritt
weiter gehen und sagen lasst uns eine
tasse kaffee trinken wenn ich das
nächste mal in zürich bin
lass uns treffen weil das ihre beziehung
bereichert und sie auf eine neue stufe
befördert mich hat das so überzeugt das
ist die art und weise wie ich mein leben
organisiere verändert hat meine tägliche
routine hat sich verändert
eine schriftstellerin muss zb viel zeit
alleine verbringen
sie müssen das tun um kreativ zu sein
wenn sie schreiben brauchen sie zeit zum
überlegen während der sie nicht
unterbrochen werden
als folge der neuen informationen in
diesem buch realisierte ich aber dass
das keine gute idee ist dass ich das
besser andere so integrierte ich soziale
kontakte in meinen tag so wie man die
zeit im fitnessraum strukturieren würde
ich musste jeden tag einige haben genau
wie meine vitamine oder mein café ich
integrierte sie auch in meine routine
ich pflegte allein zu trainieren ich
schwamm runden im pool jetzt schwimme
ich mit einem schwimm team
ich sehe sie jede woche drei mal wir
bauen beziehungen auf wir sehen einander
auf partys oder zum nach dessen so komme
ich nicht nur zu meinem herz kreislauf
training sondern auch zu meinem sozialen
training und das sind sie erinnern sich
die mittleren bindungen
das hängt nicht unbedingt die leute die
mich zum arzt fahren würden aber diese
leute wenn ich nicht auftauche rufen sie
mich an und fragen was ist mit tieren
gibt es tage wo sie sagen oh noch meine
sozialen verpflichtungen und ist so ein
bisschen verfluchen
ich bin nicht wirklich introvertiert und
es gibt viel weniger menschen die
wirklich introvertiert sind als
gemeinten aber ich glaube wir müssen es
gleich sehen wie einem großen dicken
saftigen hamburger oder ein großes
dickes fettes schnitten wir alle essen
das liebend gern wir alle fühlen
intuitiv dass ihr darf zu gehen wollen
aber tatsache ist dass ich mich gut mit
den sozialen kontakten ist es das
gleiche sie müssen vereinbart werden ich
hoffe sie werden vereinbart
ich hoffe ein gespräch in gang zu
bringen bei denen die leute realisieren
ja für manche leute ist es schwierig ja
es braucht eine vor
es braucht mehr anstrengung als eine sms
oder e-mail zu verschicken
das digitale ist der weg des geringsten
widerstands aber die anstrengung lohnt
sich genauer sich lohnt das essen selber
zuzubereiten
ich muss sagen vieles überzeugt mich
sehr was sie sagen dass wir auch sehr
sympathisch zudem ist journalistisch
gutgeschrieben süffig viele geschichten
man merkt da ist eine autorin eine
journalistin am werk frage trotzdem die
frage könnte sein dass sie das so sehen
und das auch mir das so sympathisch ist
ein bisschen damit zu tun haben auch mit
unserer generation also dass sie ein
bisschen dem mythos des goldenen
zeitalters so wie es für uns immer war
verfallen und das schön finden könnte
sein da anders gefragt das junge
generationen das spielen integrieren um
nicht mehr nötig
diese direkten kontakte wie wir menschen
in unserer generation das haben oder
waren sie das geld wirklich für alle
es gilt für alle
wir alle sind menschliche wesen wir alle
sind homo sapiens es stimmt dass die
junge generation die mit digitalen
geräten aufgewachsen ist damit einen
lockereren umgang pflegt tatsache ist
aber auch dass es eine gegenreaktion
gibt auch in der jüngeren generation
menschen wollen authentische erfahrungen
die junge generation will spezial bier
trinken kein industrielles bier
sie wollen echte erfahrungen sie wollen
klettern sie wollen keine digitalen
klettererfahrung indem sie eine brille
anziehen
mit der sie felsen sehen als wären sie
dort sie wollen die welt fühlen und
berühren wie alle anderen auch meine
angst ist weniger dass es unterschiede
zwischen den generationen gibt als das
klassenspezifische unterschiede
geschaffen werden dass leute die es sich
leisten können für echte persönliche
erfahrungen bezahlen während jene die es
nicht vermögen nun lasst sie
elektronisch genießen
du kannst deine digitalen geräte
benutzen du brauchst dich nicht zu
treffen
du kannst keinen während leute die es
sich leisten können ein flugzeug zu
besteigen und zu reisen hinfliegen und
ihre probleme persönlich lösen alle
wissenschaftler zum beispiel sind
digital verbunden
darüber gibt es keinen zweifel aber aus
gewissen gründen besteigen
wissenschaftler flugzeuge und reisen
regelmäßig um den halben globus an
konferenzen warum weil sie diese art von
kreativität und vermischung von ideen
brauchen die aus dem zusammensein mit
anderen entsteht und neue ideen
hervorbringt ein sehr interessanter
punkt auch wir müssen zum schluss kommen
die tochter die sie begleitet hat nach
sardinien die nächste kommunikation wird
die persönlich sein oder über skype oder
telefon mit meiner tochter
gesagt habe ich mag's kalb nicht für
private beziehungen fürs private
beziehungen mag ich wirklich das telefon
für distanzierte beziehungen wie zu
journalisten ist in ordnung dogmatik
rinnen sind frau pink ich bedanke mich
herzlich für das gespräch
thank you so much nicht nur die
kommunikation auch die kunst hat sich
längst aus dem physischen ins luftig
picks live der weiterentwickelt die
schweizerin pipilotti rist die gerade
eine vielbeachtete ausstellung im
kunsthaus zürich zeigt gehört mit ihrer
videokunst unterdessen zu den ganz
großen ihrer zunft in der sternstunde
kunst jetzt gleich lässt sie uns dabei
zuschauen wie sie ihre sinnlichen
spielten werke bildet und entstehen
lässt ich danke fürs zuschauen
[Musik]